good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas raider nation at
allegiant stadium treated everyone to a
thrilling game filled with twists and of
course turns and now the excitement for
their season is building even more
sports director chris matthews joining
us with last night's epic overtime win
hey chris how you doing guys i'll tell
you this is so unbelievable you can't
throw around the word epic about last
night's thriller because it's bigger
than that it's called the monday night
miracle now because the raiders win the
game twice everybody players coaches
fans thought the raiders had won on the
first overtime drive it looks like brian
edwards fights and dives into the end
zone for the game-winner
back in the day seemingly every play
that wasn't reviewed has now reviewed
that it wouldn't have been a touchdown
back then but it well they called it off
now but the officials looked at it his
knee was down to one so this is where it
gets kind of crazy derek carr tries to
sneak in they get penalized carr throws
a pick off the helmet of a raven
baltimore then takes over and lamar
jackson fumbles the ball raiders ball
again this time las vegas outsmarts the
ravens carr tossing to zay jones for the
game-winner hey this time it counts
vegas celebrates a 33-27 win
and i just think
this stadium i think the people that
were here tonight will
um
probably go home feeling like they had a
pretty good time i just i just thought
it was really a great scene a lot of
black a lot of noise a lot of devoted
committed fans that that i just love and
cherish
all right what makes this game so
special for raider nation and las vegas
it was really the first true home game
for the raiders tough to count last
year's game without a home field
advantage in fact last year across the
nfl they went 127 128 and 1. so actually
the home fields finished below 500 for
the first time in nfl history kirsten oh
and chris you've been covering this for
decades
home team first time in front of the
fans what was this like for you oh it
was really really neat because all those
fans came in vaccinated there weren't
masks around uh you had a few people
with mass that had just got that one
first vaccination but it was neat just
to see raider nation that we had
witnessed in oakland now back here in
las vegas and celebrating coming from
all corners of the united states and
really some from overseas as well just
to be here for this opener and it
certainly didn't disappoint anybody out
there is a lot of fun
thanks so much chris we'll check back
with you